[Music]  bye  [Music]  so  foreign  [Music]  um  [Music]  so  [Music]  hello  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  hello  [Music]  so  [Music]  you  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  so  [Music]  foreign  so  [Music]  ah  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  so  so  [Music]  hmm  you  [Music]  so  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  so  [Music]  um  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  uh  [Music]  huh  uh  [Music]  so  [Music]  hmm  do  [Music]  huh  [Music]  um  [Music]  my  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  so  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  that's  [Music]  time  [Music]  so  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  huh  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  oh  [Music]  this  hmm  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  so  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  hello  [Music]  hey  [Music]  so  [Music]  that's  [Music]  ah  oh yes  [Music]  you